a recent study published in personality
and individual differences found that
women who are high in intersexual
competitiveness are more likely to
advise women who they perceive as
potential mating threats to cut off more
hair in an attempt to sabotage their
attractiveness the researchers studied
450 women who are presented with
hypothetical Salon clients participants
were asked to recommend the amount of
hair to be cut off for each woman women
who reported high levels of intrasexual
competitiveness were more likely to
recommend that clients have more hair
cut off when the hair was in good
condition and the clients expressed a
preference for minimal cutting another
finding is that women advise clients of
similar attractiveness as themselves to
cut off the most hair participants
effectively targeted women they
perceived as being on the same
attractiveness level potentially to try
and reduce their attractiveness longer
hair is a cue to Youth and health yeah
men love long hair I don't think women
realize how much men love long hair